[Music]
hello everyone thank you very much for
joining us this afternoon or this
morning whenever you're watching this
presentation
my name is dr weston umstead and i am
the technology and business development
manager for cairo technologies located
in westchester pennsylvania i have a
number of responsibilities here
one of which is the
method development screening
and method development optimization
process that we'll talk a little bit
about today
specifically for cannabinoids um but i'm
also responsible for a number of uh
preparative outsourced and in-sourced uh
separations projects
which we don't really cover those
applications too much in today's
presentation
but certainly if that sounds like that's
something that's interesting to you i
can i'd be more than happy to have a
conversation with you about those
at some point but i've been with cairo
technologies for a little over five
years now uh started out doing some
synthesis work on a dfinity genomics
project which was essentially just a pcr
cleanup
affinity resin
and then moved into the chiral core
business
which is the the topic of conversation
for today
dicel chiro technologies or dicel
corporation as you might know it a
little bit more
broadly is the
leader global leader in polysaccharide
based chiral stationary phases and so
the topic today is going to be a number
of applications that have been developed
using these phases
both for achiral and chiral separation
of cannabinoids
so just a couple of bullet points here
for for what we're going to be
covering today the topics of interest
for those of you who are joining us who
might not be too familiar with
chirochromatography i thought it would
be a good place to start to talk about
a little bit of the history of of
chirochromatography and and why it is so
important or what its other applications
have been used for
but of course the majority of what we're
going to talk about is is the
cannabinoid separation so post 2018 with
the passage of the farm bill what were
sort of the initial applications that
these phases were used for
and then more recently as the the field
has expanded and the number of chiral
cannabinoids have been identified
what sort of applications these phases
have been used for for those types of
separations
so let's start first with the uh the
background
so as you may or may not know from your
history books or from
billy joel or some other source
uh thalidomide was sort of the
first case if you will
where the
structure of the molecule was really
pinpointed as being important for its
function in the body
so in the late 1950s and the early 60s
thalidomide was being prescribed to uh
pregnant mothers for uh assisting with
morning sickness
but as their children were being born
they were being born with some pretty
severe birth defects and so
uh sort of later on down the line it was
it was found that the r enantiomer which
is up on the screen as the left molecule
uh was the therapeutic and the s
enantiomer on the right
was the um
the one that was causing the the severe
birth defects but thalidomide wasn't
necessarily the first case where
this sort of chirality thing was noticed
or was uh
was noted as being important there were
a number of earlier accounts
sort of
sharing the differences that were
arising from natural structures so the
french physicist biatt
noticed that there was some optical
activity in the structure of quartz
there was actually two different
handedness
forms of the crystalline structure of
quartz
of course you might be familiar with
louis pasteur and his experiments with
tartaric acid
unfortunately he had the task of
separating them by hand
today it's much more convenient for the
separation of these enantiomers
historically because of solidimide and
because of a number of other cases where
the structure of a compound equaled some
sort of a
physical
indication in the body the
pharmaceutical industry has been one of
the greatest adapters and users of the
chiral chromatography the polysaccharide
based chirochromatography products it's
estimated something like eighty percent
of all drugs that are developed uh
whether they are commercialized or not
it's a different story but roughly
eighty percent of the drugs that are
considered for one indication or another
contain some sort of a chiral center so
remembering back to
chemistry high school chemistry days or
the dreaded organic chemistry days of
undergrad
a chiral center we're talking about a
tetrahedral carbon so carbon that has
four different things attached to it
but carbon is not the only chiral center
nitrogen sulfur and phosphorus can also
be
chiral depending upon what substituents
they have attached to them
a lot of different cases in the
literature that are pharmaceuticals
things like non-steroidal and
anti-inflammatory drugs beta blockers
antidepressants and many many more
i just have a few examples structures on
the screen here on the left hand side is
ace butylol which is a beta blocker
in the center is cetalopram which is an
ssri
and on the right hand side is fluoxetine
or prozac which is also an ssri
now i talked about the
some of the the services that are i'm a
part of here at chiro technologies one
of them being
the method development screening
there are a number of interactions that
can take place between the chiral
analyte and the chiral stationary phase
the chiral stationary phases that we're
talking about are either cellulose or
amylose-based
and those cellulose and amylose polymers
form a left-handed helical twist
structure and in doing so they form what
we like to call chiral grooves and think
about dna double-stranded dna
where the the groove is where a lot of
the interaction can take place with
outside
compounds coming in
so left-handed helical twists these
chiral grooves within them have what we
call chiral selectors and there's these
small
phenyl groups either phenyl carbamates
or benzo benzoates
that can form a number of intermolecular
interactions between the chiral
stationary phase and the analyte i
summarized here in the table
some of the main
interaction interactive forces that take
place between the chiral stationary
phases and the analytes
the ones that we're most interested in
usually are hydrogen bonding steer
hindrance pi pi interaction and dipole
dipole
generally speaking the others take place
but don't have as much of an influence
on
the actual separation of a compound
and the three-point interaction model
shown to the right
which is really a sort of a drug binding
model but it represents the point
what we look for is at least three
points of interaction on the chiral
stationary phase that line up with
functional groups that are on the active
or the inactive enantiomer or the
enantiomer that is going to be more
strongly retained or eluded earlier in
the hplc method and so if there is a
lining up of those functional groups
with the points of interaction on the
chiral stationary phase
the opposite enantiomer although it has
the same functional groups as you can
see
in the center of that right figure the
inactive enantiomer they don't line up
as well with the points of interaction
on the chiral stationary phase so
there's a difference in energy that
takes place between active and inactive
and we hope that there is enough of an
energy difference that eventually
propagates into a chiral separation
and even if you were to take that
inactive enantiomer and rotate it
there's still not a match up of those
points of interaction so still enough of
an energy difference to see a separation
of the of the enantiomers
in reality it's a lot more complicated
than that because you have to consider
everything as solvated by mobile phase
uh if you have a polar organic solvent
present like ethanol or methanol there's
certainly going to be blocking or
promoting of certain interactions
so what we like to do is we start off
with a method development screening
which allows us to check the chiral
analyte on all of the different
polysaccharide phases under a wide range
of different mobile phase combinations
and that usually is sufficient enough
then to help us find a chiral separation
to be able to get begin our method
development process
now for
cannabinoids
as i sort of laid the foundation in the
introduction cannabinoids initially post
2018 in the the farm bill
really the focus was on
quantifying or identifying the presence
of or lack thereof of thc
in cbd products so the farm bill
essentially legalized the regulated
production of hemp
and by extension the production of cbd
or cannabidiol which is a non-controlled
substance according to the dea
but it had the caveat of course that all
cbd products needed to contain less than
0.3 percent of delta 9
tetrahydrocannabinol
delta 9 thc so that was sort of the
initial target application and
many of the
a chiral phases that were available
c18 for instance were
widely known and cost effective based on
previous technologies that were
established and they worked well because
cbd and thc are not chiral molecules of
each other
they are not structurally related and so
things like c18 or phenyl or amine or
other commonly available commercialized
achirophases work very well and
probably know this very well there's a
number of application notes and papers
and posters and so forth on this topic
those phases work really well and the
methods have been
integrated in a lot of different labs
across the the us
now interestingly enough although
i set the stage for chiral stationary
phases and chiral separations
the chiral environment that's created by
the left-handed twist of these
polysaccharides
is also capable of doing eight chiral
separations as well which makes them
sort of dual purpose they can do
the later applications that i'll talk
about the chiral separations but also
these other applications here
that i'll show you earlier on for a
chiral separation so early on uh the
first applications that were developed
were supercritical fluid chromatography
based that is a chromatography that uses
supercritical co2 as the primary mobile
phase component
a lot of this was done uh because of the
green advantages uh sfc technology just
like
supercritical fluid extraction uses a
considerably less amount of organic
solvent and so the cost is generally
lower and of course a little better for
the environment in getting rid of the
organic solvents
if you look at the separation of this 10
cannabinoid mixture
that's commercially available from
cayman chemical in michigan on
immobilized cellulose tris 35 dimethyl
phenyl carbamate with 15 methanol as a
modifier you get a nice baseline
resolution of a number of different
cannabinoids here everything from
cbd and delta 9 thc which was the
primary target
to
things like delta a thc
cbg cbn and so forth
these
also work really well under normal phase
high performance liquid chromatography
conditions although not as green
the separations are maintained when you
move to
mixtures of things like hexane ipa or
hexane ethanol
with the same chiral stationary phase
that i showed in the last slide here
mobilized cellulose tris 35 dimethyl
phenyl carbonate with 96 hexane 3 ipa
and 1 ethanol a little bit of tfa
you get again the nice baseline
resolution of that same 10 cannabinoid
mixture now the difference between sfc
and hplc aside from the mobile phase
components
is the fact that in this case normal
phase you need to have an acidic
additive sfc is slightly acidic in its
nature the co2 will exist as
a carbonic acid water co2 mixture that
you might be familiar with so the
carbonic acid is normally enough to take
care of the acidic
cannabinoids like thca
however on normal phase it's a
relatively neutral mobile phase and so
you need to add something like
trifluoroacetic acid or formic acid
usually to help improve the peak shape
of the acidic cannabinoids
but in any case the the separation is
maintained as you can see here
just another example very similar mobile
phase conditions
this is an an immobilized amylose tris s
alpha methyl benzyl carbamate also
commercially known as chiropac ih uh
same separation of of that 10
cannabinoid mixture
now this sort of sets the stage a little
bit
you'll notice the
second column over in the aleutian time
you see cbc which is cannabis chromine i
have listed there two different elution
times and that is because cbc is one of
those few
cannabinoids that's actually
racemic naturally occurring and so under
these methods although they were sort of
focused primarily on the achiral
separations we were actually seeing both
the mixed chiral and a chiral
separations taking place which sort of
leads into the uh the applications at
the end of this presentation
and then lastly uh reversed phase high
performance uh or high high performance
liquid chromatography
water-based mobile phases
i would say it's sort of the the mix
between sfc and normal phase a little
bit greener in the fact that it's
aqueous based
but of course you're still dealing with
some organic solvent in this case it is
acetyl nitrile this is a separation of
that same mixture on immobilized amylose
tris
3-chloro-5-methylphenyl carbamate with
45 percent water and 5 55 percent
acidity trial again
because it's uh not sfc you do need the
addition of the acidic additive just to
help with the
acidic residues
now if we start looking a little bit
more specifically
at the chiral cannabis separations i
said i set the stage in the last
separations that the the separation of
cbc
so we can start there
um
you see here that cbc happens to be
later in this
[Music]
three chloro5 methyl phenyl carbamate uh
immobilized amylose method
if we shift gears a little bit and and
do just a screening of it we'll find
some very interesting results that help
us improve upon the retention that was
sort of set forth in in those other
methods
as you may or may not know
cannabis chromine can undergo a uv
cyclization process whether it be
naturally or as a result of storage
conditions to canon by cyclolog i have
the structure of both of those shown
here as sort of the uv
degradation process
up in the left hand corner the structure
of canada by chromine has the chiral
center starred it's alpha to the
the oxygen in the sex-membered ring
and of course when it goes and is
cyclized that chiral center is not lost
it is maintained
and you get the structure that is shown
in the bottom right of the slide for the
cannabis cyclone so if we mix these two
things together
or on the right hand side canada by
chromine by itself and we do that of
method development screening
on immobilized cellulose tris 35
dimethyl phenyl carbonate it will roll
off your tongue the more you say it
with 97 hexane 3 ethanol
you get a nice baseline resolution of
cbc and on the left-hand side mix it in
with the canon by psyclaw uh a nice four
peak separation again it's a chiral
mixed chiral a chiral separation as
you're achieving uh the separation of
both things and really the side-by-side
comparison here is to help
show illusion order so the cannabis
cyclol is very well resolved coming out
peak one and peak four and the cannabis
chromine is the third and second and
third peaks respectively
if we start looking at
thc itself thc naturally occurs only as
one enantiomer however it does have the
potential to form both the plus and
minus delta nine variant
more synthetically than naturally
occurring but nevertheless it also has
the same potential to develop the minus
and plus enantiomers for the delta eight
thc
uh delta eight thc now becoming quite
popular in the um in the industry as a
product as a that's available because
it's not a control it's not a controlled
substance so it's sort of a workaround
for the dea restrictions
but if we mix these four things together
again this would be a mixed chiral a
chiral separation between delta 8 delta
9 a chiral and then plus minus chiral
we get a nice baseline resolution of all
four enantiomers or four
isomers on amylose tris three
chloro4methylphenyl carbamate with 95
hexane and 5
ipa
again these are all now non-acidic
cannabinoids so there's no need for an
acidic additive like we saw when we were
dealing with thc a
a for instance
some of the other thc variants now also
uh occurring or showing up a little bit
more frequently delta six thc and delta
ten thc uh really it's it's the longer
names that i have shown on the
pictures here but it's a little easier
just to say delta 6 and delta delta 10
for presentation purposes
but much like delta 8 and delta 9 it's a
mixed chiral a chiral separation between
the chiral delta 6 and delta 10
separately and the a chiral mixture
together
we have a nice baseline resolution for
that under normal phase hplc conditions
the immobilized cellulose tris
3-5-dimethylphenyl carbamate is as you
might have gathered so far a very useful
chiral separa chiral stationary phase
for these sorts of separations
it shows a very wide range of
selectivity across a number of different
cannabinoid mixtures i can't necessarily
call it a cannabinoid column but it does
a very good job at separating a lot of
these different mixtures
but in any case here for delta 6 and
delta 10 you see here
sort of an interesting illusion order
where you've got the delta 6 variants
coming out at 3 4 peaks 3 and 4 and then
the delta 10 variance coming out at
peaks one and peaks two
but if we go and we switch up the chiral
stationary phase to
uh cellulose tris three chloro5 methyl
phenyl carbonate
uh which is chiropac ig you get a little
bit of the shuffling of the aleutian
order so you get delta uh six
and delta
the the two enantiomers of delta six
coming out one and two now and the two
enantiomers of delta ten coming out
three and four
uh i mentioned that only because uh for
preparative separations it's it's always
a good handle to be able to change
illusion order generally speaking your
peaks of interest you want to elute
first so should you want to adapt this
to a preparative chiral separation
having the ability to mix or switch
around the aleutian order is kind of
important for that
so where are we headed just a couple of
closing remarks here where we headed
not surprisingly i would say that
as time goes on and the legal status of
a lot of these different cannabinoids
begins to evolve that you're going to
start to see a lot of additional
regulation
much like was the case early on with
needing to quantify the percentage of
thc in cbd products it would not
surprise me if the regulation evolves to
needing to measure the level of delta 8
thc for instance
hhc which is hexahydrocannabinol
cannabidiol has now become another
workaround for the legal status of delta
9 thc
we have a number of
applications that have been developed on
on the separations of hhc now as well
but having proper testing for that
the presence of opposite enantiomers
might also become
something of interest
cbd for instance is
not only commercially available but it's
also prescribed as a pharmaceutical
and so the need for
characterizing the opposite enantiomer
much like was the case for thalidomide
might also arise for cbd or any of the
other cannabinoids that become
registered pharmaceuticals for different
applications
and so the take-home message for this
presentation really is that chiral
columns can can do it all
as these sort of regulations do become
more relevant or more prominent
a chiral methods that don't separate out
the enantiomers aren't going to be
sufficient anymore and so
we have hopefully started to lay the
groundwork for those
those applications
a lot of what you have seen here is all
nice clean analytical standards so
for us and sort of for application
development the next step is taking
these and putting them into real world
samples and kind of messing the samples
up a little bit and complicating them
and adding in other cannabinoids and
things like that to see
how exactly
we can go about using these for for
accurate quantification and
identification
uh if you like the information that
you've heard today um if you want to
reach out to me and and have a broader
discussion on chirochromatography or a
more specific one on these applications
please feel free to reach out to me my
email address is shown on the screen now
wombstead chiral cti.daisel.com
or feel free to give me a call on my
office phone
extension 264
i would love to have a conversation with
you about these and other applications
of
chirochromatography so i appreciate it
very much again for
your time and attention today and i look
forward to discussing these with you
more
in the near future thank you
you